[Music]
what I feel and I am dancing I feel free
I just feel confident I feel strong I
feel in control of Who I am
I knew this is what I wanted to do I
didn't want to do anything else but it
may be
[Music]
my name is Akira Armstrong and I'm the
CEO and founder a pretty big movement
which is a full circuit professional
dance company
I start a pretty big movement nine years
ago and I felt that there was a void and
mainstream media where it wasn't a
platform for plus-sized professional
dancers I didn't fit in even walking
into auditions I didn't feel like I
belong
the typical expected body type is the
ballerinas you know the long legs the
long arms long torso it's upsetting that
society puts this label on dancers
because for me it's about the talent I
had booked this major gig with Beyonce I
decided well let me audition for more
representation I auditioned for at least
five different agencies and they all
kept saying the same thing she's good we
don't know how to market her and I got
tired of hearing that even though I
struggle with things it was my passion
something that I wanted to do is
something that I loved and I kept
pushing it kept pushing and kept pushing
and it just got to a point where I was
like this is really what I want to do we
came up with the name pretty big and
from there I said I need a pack of girls
who know how to move who know how to
dance we have a range of young ladies
who are professional dancers they work
hard to prove themselves not only for me
but also for themselves five six seven
here we go in a 1 and a 2 and a 3 charge
one thing is that we do is our pretty
big movement workshop anybody is welcome
to come to our workshops I am pretty big
I am powerful because I feel nothing but
loving we do power circles and that
portion of the workshop becomes very
emotional each and every day I'm
learning to love myself and just the
timing I can't keep now we have had
people say I'll be divorced I'll be
suicide I was a rape victim I beat
cancer so I wasn't employed this is so
funny enough to just fill it all out the
misconceptions that people have about
plus-sized women we are lazy we have low
self-esteem we don't care about our
appearance
we are non-existent and we exist this is
who I am
plus-sized and fabulous
you
[Music]